[Musik]
kompanie auf mein kommando ich fasse die
letzten zwei anstrengenden monaten
zusammen haben begonnen mit einzige
feldschiessen bis rauf zum kompanie
feldschiessen maschine gelände die
leistung war durchaus in ordnung
[Musik]
erster zug sowie zweiter zug halten
vorerst gewonnenes gelände und treten
auf befehl weiter an um in fantastische
aufklärung im bereich chamäleon hügel zu
vernichten
sonst keine veränderungen zu gestern
auftrag kommt dann sowieso noch mal aus
der bewegung okay gibt es fragen seien
hunderte tiere ja
kompromissbereit
gezeigt und meinung ist jetzt fertig wir
treten an um 12.30 aufgesessen geschickt
verstanden hast du geschafft
[Musik]
hätte gern gut
das ganze gruppe lage promotion wir
gehen hinter 220 helfer kümmert hat wie
er schließe da verstanden
20 21 jahren vollkommen
legal fragestellung schutz zu
[Musik]
ja verstanden zur eigenen ihre eigene
partei setzte sich ab
bevor ich den feldherrenhügel
[Musik]
jetzt hauptsächlich ein wohlverdientes
wochenende für ihn in diesem sinne
hartes wochenende abtreten